I hate to get on this topic but your
Parks and Recreation pal Chris Pratt was
here recently and he's shared with us
something that you he and Nick Offerman
do right do you know where I'm going
with this yeah I'm sorry okay it's a
thing the three of you do you've been
doing it for a while
yeah and it's it's one of the odder
things I've ever heard of why don't you
tell us what that's all about and what
it is I'd love to Conan it's you know
it's just a thing that I don't know I
would imagine
Offerman started it where the three of
us every once in a while not every day
not every week not even every month just
every once in a while we'll send each
other a photo of a particularly
memorable movement we've had right
bowels set is that yeah yeah bow and
about it
but if you guys have a particularly
prodigious or healthy one you take a
picture of it and you share it with each
other
well it's disgusting but you know and
and it's not it's that we're not like
tied to it's it's a very non-committal
thing but but yeah every once in a while
like just recently I think I got one
from Nick and it said happy Presidents
Day
and I think I think at one point I may
have sent one and just said hey how
about those Oscar nom now it makes sense
to me there you go now it makes sense to
me
alright are you gonna continue doing
that for quite some time oh god I don't
know okay
you